why don't I take you through and you can
have a little look around Adam and I are
going to walk around this is the sky
Studios it's just across the road
actually from where Sky News's this is
generally where the sports programs come
from so we'll be going into the studio
where people like Jamie Redknapp film
sarah-jane me and alike and tonight for
one night only we are going to be able
to see the leader of the Opposition Mr
Miliband and also the president Prime
Minister David Cameron which is going to
go into the studios
can we show them here when it says on
the door perhaps Adam flowset do not
enter without permission thankfully we
do have permission to come in now
because the ink was only dry on the
contract on Saturday afternoon we have
really been working 24/7 to get this set
together for you we were rehearsing
yesterday
I was playing mr. Cameron on occasion
and Mr Miliband on occasion as well
we've got something like seven to ten
questions for each of them around about
18 minutes or something like that let me
go through again what Dermot was telling
you so we'll say hello then have
actually have a look at the set first
that's what you're most interested in
isn't it so you can see we've got Mr
Miliband here photographs you can see
the boy sister you're right there boys
don't worry you can see this is still a
work in progress as you can see Mr
Miliband there and then right in the
middle number 10 and then of course mr.
Cameron here now this is going to be my
election this is where I will be
standing later on this is where I'm
going to be asking those questions via
the audience and that is where the
leader of the Opposition and the Prime
Minister will be sitting we're not sure
actually whether they want to sit sorry
about my back whether they want to sit
or whether they'll want election like
mine there's only one I've got it so I'm
guessing they're going to have the seat
instead